KRISTIN GENIS-LUND: Hi,
thank you for coming.
My name is Kristin Genis-Lund.
And I'm a Googler and an opera
singer, so it is my pleasure
and I'm honored to be able to
introduce Sheri Greenawald who
is the director of the
San Francisco Opera Center
as well as the artistic director
of the Merola Program in San
Francisco.
Most of you have already read
her bio, so I won't read it.
However, I can tell you
that suffice it to say she
is an amazing
international artist that
has sung so many roles in so
many prestigious opera houses
around the world.
Since then, she's been
one of the cornerstones
of vocal mentorship in the
Bay Area for young singers.
If you'll indulge
me, I'd just love
to tell a quick story
how she and I met.
My brother was actually the
third spirit in San Francisco
opera productions of Magic
Flute back in the '80s
when Sheri sang "Pamina."
So I got to meet her
when I was a young child,
and then was having
a crisis deciding
whether to be a concert
violinist or a singer.
And so my violin teacher,
who was friends with Sheri,
told me to go and visit her.
And she said, close
your eyes and imagine
you being in an orchestra
rehearsal for eight hours,
and imagine you singing
for eight hours.
Which would you rather do?
And that answered the question.
So there you go.
Anyway, I'm pleased to
introduce Sheri Greenawald.
Please give her a warm welcome.
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Thank you, my dear.
KRISTIN GENIS-LUND: Mm.
You're welcome.
SHERI GREENAWALD: Well, she's
given a few my bona fides,
as we call it.
You know a little about me.
I did sing internationally,
absolutely.
And I was lucky enough
to sing with some
of the great conductors,
including-- I had some really
great time with
Leonard Bernstein.
I premiered his
final opera and got
to hang out with Lenny,
which is never bad and got
to ask Seiji Ozawa
how he-- I asked him,
do you have a
photographic memory?
Because I was
always so impressed
with Seiji Ozawa's
ability to never
have a score in front of him.
And he said no,
I work very hard.
And that was a
great thing to say.
Because I thought, ah-hah.
You see?
You don't have to have
a photographic memory.
You just have to work hard,
ladies and gentlemen, which
is what I'm always
telling my singers.
You've just got to be down in
that practice room at 8:00 AM.
Get down there.
I'm not a pedagogue.
I wasn't trained as a
pedagogue, and I only
sang opera professionally,
lead roles,
for 30 years of my
life to earn my living.
That's how I did it.
So I do have the hands-on
knowledge, as it were,
and I also have been teaching
formally, more or less,
for about 20 years now, taught
at the Boston Conservatory.
I've been around.
But I grew up in the middle
of the cornfields of Iowa,
so I came to this in as weird
a way as anyone can, I think.
Except we did have the
Firestone Hour back in my day.
And you watched Eleanor Steber
and people like that sing,
and you get stimulated, I think.
So that was a good thing.
How does the voice work, right?
People are always curious.
Of course, we can go
into a lot of pedagogy,
and I do like to
know the reality.
I was telling someone at lunch
that I went to a teacher,
and his solution for most things
was, well, bite the apple.
And unfortunately,
I was the daughter
of two science teachers.
And so I would say, well,
how big is that apple
and what color is it?
And I don't know, because I knew
large apples and crab apples.
And so that didn't work for me.
Then I finally did me the
teacher named Audrey Langford,
who was British.
I met her in Santa
Fe, New Mexico,
where she taught every summer.
And Audrey was the
first person to say
to me, where's your tongue?
I said, I don't know.
And she said, well, it's
halfway down your throat.
I said, OK.
OK.
So we got the pliers out,
and we got rid of that.
And so Audrey would say to
you, I can tell you so much.
Then you've got to go
read "Gray's Anatomy."
Well, I am a girl that
owns a "Gray's Anatomy,"
and it sits by my piano at home.
So I did do that.
So what do we do?
This is interactive.
I just wanted you to know this.
You're going to help
me out here today.
The first thing
we do, of course,
is we have to figure out
what do these vocal cords do?
They close.
It's an act.
We call it closure.
It's called adduction.
There's another
terminology for it,
but anyway, there are a lot of
terminologies for what this is.
The vocal cords sit
open, and then they
close to create sound.
Of course, the tongue
is right there too.
And so this whole
part of your throat
is involved in several things.
The tongue is
protecting the windpipe.
So you've got the windpipe
right behind the larynx.
So there's a lot of stuff going
on in that area of your throat.
But these little cords, in the
male, they're a little longer.
They're about two, maybe
to 2.5 centimeters.
And in the female, they're
anywhere from 1.75 centimeters
long to two something.
Teeny pieces of gristle
that I earn my living
with for all these years.
They're little bitty
things, but they sit open
for the most time.
And then when you phonate--
phonation-- they close, right?
That's what they do.
That's how we do it.
And you can feel it.
I always say we can all do
ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah.
Can you hear that?
I'm just touching my
cords without sounding.
Can you do that?
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah.
You feel that point.
Singers become so
familiar with that point
because that is, particularly
if you have a gentle onset,
you know exactly where
that point of contact is.
You have an incredible
relationship
with that sensation
of that touch.
You know exactly where that is.
The perfect
phonation, the breath
becomes exactly as
the cords close.
But there are other types
of onset that can happen.
You can have what we
call a breathier onset,
and that's when the cords
don't close right away,
and you get sort of ahhh.
And it's sort of ahhh.
And I'm keeping a little
more space, actually
between my cords.
Perfect closure, they're not
completely closed either.
There's a teeny small gap
if that's a perfect closure.
But a breathier one, you
keep them even further apart.
And they don't close
quite all the way.
But then there's also
the glottal attack.
We use glottal stops in the
German language, particularly.
That's one you may
know because you
have to put a glottal
stop before the vowel
onsets in German language.
So the glottal stop is just--
the stop happens a little
before the breath.
And so it's ah, ah.
You bring your cords together.
Try that.
You bring them together.
Ah.
And then you bring the breath.
That sort of a
glottal stop onset.
That's what that is.
And that is used, like I
say, in the German language.
And so if you're singing
beautiful Schubert songs,
you're doing a lot of glottal
stopping here and there.
So those are the different kinds
of onsets that we can produce.
So the breath is coming
through the vocal cords
and making them phonate.
And of course, one of the
most interesting things
about singing is also
the Bernoulli Effect.
I know you're bunch of
engineers in here possibly.
How many of you know
the Bernoulli Effect?
Here, we got one--
several over here, right?
It's what gets the
airplane into the air?
It's what makes
that baseball spin?
And believe me, I don't
understand it very well,
but I do understand this.
I do understand that when
I close my vocal cords
and send air, which is what
we do, you're sending air
and you've closed this space,
it's creating a compression.
And on me, you can
actually see what we call
the subglottal compression.
Maybe you can see it.
I'll walk closer to you.
It looked like a bladder
filled up on my neck.
It really well.
And this is called
subglottal compression.
So here we go.
I'll give it a try.
Here we go.
So it's going to go
(SINGING) ahhhhhhhhh.
You see how that totally fell
in when I stopped singing?
That's subglottal compression.
So I built up air under the
cords, and what that does
is it then blows that cord open.
And that's how you get this
oscillation that's happening.
And the cords, as they
come back together,
you get a slight variation
in the pitch because of this.
Because the vocal
cords are doing this.
They're coming
together, turning,
and then blowing apart,
coming together, turning,
blowing apart.
When you're on an A in
the middle of the voice--
an A is about 440-- your vocal
cords are slamming together
at about 440 times a second, OK?
So about where I
was-- (SINGING) ahh--
that's probably a little
high even. (SINGING) Ahhh.
My cords are slapping
at 440 a second.
If I sing a high C, somewhere
around-- (SINGING) ahhh!--
that's going to be about 1,000
times a second that your vocal
cords are slapping together.
And they're doing
this wild thing.
So the only way to really see
them as under a strobe light.
You can't really
isolate this vision
without strobes when they
do hard scopes at the voice
doctor.
So that's what's happening
in that throat, which
I think for some people feels
rather violent in a way.
And it is sort of a
violent little action
that's going on there.
And what I call singing
is sustained scream.
[LAUGHTER]
Because when we talk, we
don't sustain the pitch,
unless you're like me
and a little sing-songy
and you start to
stretch out a word,
then you're sort of
sustaining as a singer does.
But what a singer
is doing is really
sustaining more-- (SINGING) no!
That's me screaming
at my friend who's
about to step off the curb
and get hit by the Muni bus.
So I always yell no at them.
And that is what
we do when we sing.
Because you're going
to elongate that pitch,
and you're going to
keep on that pitch.
And so that is what we do.
It's a sustained scream.
And then you're bringing
this breath into the mouth.
You're bringing the sound.
It's the transference
of energy, obviously.
This is what it's all about--
transference of energy.
Then you come to something
called the vowel formants.
And you are going to
create vowels in the mouth.
The vowels are not formed
in your throat, ladies
and gentlemen, just in
case you ever thought that.
Of course, one
could argue that ah
is a laryngeal
vowel in that ah is
the vowel that ends up in the
most words for the word mother.
Because when a child starts
to speak, guess what?
Their mouth is closed,
and they will phone an m.
Because when your mouth is
closed-- mmm-- that's an m.
Mmm.
So you get an m, and then
if you just open the mouth,
you go mmmahh.
That little section,
that M-A will end up
in most words for mother
oftentimes in most languages.
It certainly is in Italian
and French, God knows.
Of course, I don't know how
the Germans got to Mutter,
but anyway, maybe their
tongues work differently.
But I know I think in
Chinese it's [? omah, ?]
and a lot of the
words for mother
always have this M-A
in it because that
is the most primal sound
that a child usually makes.
So we bring to the
vowels in the mouth.
Now, I'm always
willing to demonstrate.
The vowels themselves have
formants, the frequencies
that create these vowels.
And one of my favorite
factoids about vowels
is about the ee vowel.
And let's all try
an ee, and you'll
see what makes ee
unique as opposed to ah.
If you all say ah--
let's all say ah.
Ahhh.
You see it's very formless.
Your tongue is sort
of flat in the mouth.
You're not creating any
specific shape for it.
However, when you do
ee-- let's all say ee.
Your tongue comes up under those
teeth on the side, generally.
And your tongue-- I call it
the hump-- it's a humped vowel.
The tongue comes into this
shape inside your mouth.
It humps up in the middle.
And I always call it ee spot.
I always feel there's a point--
[CHUCKLING]
Yes, I know.
There's a spot in the
middle of your tongue
that if you want to
make a nasty, nasty ee,
that's the little spot.
So if you went, ee-eeh!
Try that everybody.
Ee-eeh!
You see what you did?
You pulled the
center of that tongue
toward the roof of your mouth.
And that increased that formant.
That increased that
ee formant and made it
a little nastier too.
And so that's the ee vowel.
It's shaped in a
very specific way.
Most singers love ee because
it does have a specific shape.
It's about the easiest vowels to
teach because you can actually
really demonstrate the space.
Whereas to find a good set of
formants for the ah vowel--
there are so many different
ahs in various languages.
In many of the Asian
languages, the ah
is centered very far back.
And so when we are dealing
with our Korean students
and Chinese students
and so forth,
you have to pull those
vowels out of the throat.
Here's a demonstration of
an ah vowel coming away
from just glottal fry, what
we call vocal fry, which
is when I leave that energy
completely just there, when
I'm not going to try to move
it into my mouth at all.
So you go ahh.
You can all do vocal fry too.
Ahh.
It's just ahh!
And it often sounds like some
crackling and frying literally.
It's sort of--
[GURGLING]
That sort of sensation.
And we call that vocal fry.
And so you can
come from vocal fry
all the way forward into
a very frontal resonance.
And I'll try to
demonstrate this.
So you sort of go ahhh.
Now that one, the last one,
was totally focused right
behind my front teeth.
The great Caruso would always
say, my voice, she is here.
And take thumb and stick it
up behind his front teeth
because indeed a
singer who's really
producing in the
resonant pocket, which
is what your speech
therapist will call it,
in the resonant pocket,
that's what your sensation is.
It's sitting right behind
your teeth-- right there.
And so ohs and oohs
are interesting too
because you can really
form them from above.
So if you say "you"--
say "you," everybody.
Do you see how this middle
muscle here under your nose
gets a little involved?
And a singer learns to use that
to increase those formants.
And this musculature is
very involved in oh and ooh.
So if you say, "no
you don't"-- say,
"no you don't." "No you don't."
You feel how those
all sort of tumble?
To me, they always feel
like they tumble down
the front of your face.
Ohs and oohs always just feel
like they're rolling around
up here like little marbles.
They feel like they look on
the page, to me, oh and ooh.
So oh and ooh are great vowels.
Ooh I would say is
the cover vowel.
Does anybody know
the term cover?
Ah, good.
Or passaggio.
The term passaggio?
And here's another
lady who knows it.
How many of you have
sung, by the way?
How many of you sing in a choir,
a rock band, in the shower,
anywhere?
Good.
So you know what we're
talking about here.
So cover is this thing.
What I call cover, the
Italians called it coperto.
Coperto means, literally,
a lid on something.
So it's something
that supposedly
happens over the vowel.
And what I think cover
is, frankly-- they're
just describing what
they're sensing.
I think it's just the
shift of resonance.
Cover is simply a
And I can demonstrate that.
You will hear a major
shift on the third pitch.
I will sing a five-note
scale, and you
will hear the sound shift
on three and slightly
on five as well.
Because I always say
about every two pitches
that larynx has to
go a little further,
and that resonance
shifts quite a bit.
Because that's what
shifts the resonance
is the shift of the larynx.
As we change pitch,
the larynx tilts over.
He tilts down and
elongates that muscle.
And that's what gives
you higher pitch.
The longer muscle gives
you the higher pitch,
the shorter muscle
gives you a lower pitch.
Go figure, right?
Doesn't seem logical to me,
but anyway-- Where was I?
The vowels.
We were where?
AUDIENCE: The passaggio.
SHERI GREENAWALD: The
passaggio, the cover.
So I'll sing a five-note
scale, and like
I said, listen to three and five
and how they differ slightly.
OK.
I have to get in the
right area of the voice.
Let's see.
How about here?
[SINGING SCALES]
Do you heart that sort of?
And five also?
[SINGING SCALES]
And you hear that top pitch.
You keep hearing the
resonances shift,
and this is what
we call the cover.
The passaggio is this incredibly
interesting part in the voice.
Every singer struggles
initially with their passaggio,
generally, unless they are
these lucky, lucky people that
don't struggle with it.
I have met two of them.
But the passaggio is where--
I asked Dr. Courey who
is the head of the
Voice and Swallowing
department at UCSF, with whom we
have a wonderful relationship.
I said to him one
day, Dr. Courey,
can you look in the throat and
tell a baritone from a tenor?
And he said, I can't even
tell a male from a female.
Well, that blew a lot of
preconceptions out of my mind.
Because we all think
that we're very unique.
Well, guess what?
We're not.
Not very unique at all.
No, the vocal cords, he did say
that certain vocal cords are
maybe a little thicker.
There might be a little thicker
cord, a slightly thinner cord,
but basically, you can't even
tell the male from the female.
And so I always love
it, because men always
think you have to treat
their voices differently
than a female voice.
And I'm going what?
No.
No, you don't.
Not really.
But anyway, where was I?
I'm always losing my track here.
AUDIENCE: The passaggio.
SHERI GREENAWALD: The passaggio.
The passaggio.
I asked Dr. Courey what it was.
And he said the
problem about studying
the passaggio is you'd have
to put electrodes in someone's
vocal cords and have them sing,
and no one's going to do that.
Because that wouldn't work.
But the working
theory Ingo Titze
is one of the leading research
persons in the voice world
and a physicist himself.
And their theory,
the working theory,
is that there is a switch of
where the tension in the cord
is from the thyroarytenoid
into the cricoarytenoid.
And so it really is an internal
switch of energy placement
within the cord itself.
And that's what
the passaggio is.
Now, singers experience
the passaggio
almost as though
they're hitting a wall.
They'll start up
a scale and go--
[SINGING SCALES]
And then they hit this
wall, and they're not quite
sure what they're experiencing.
And all it is that, if
you're having difficulty
in your passaggio,
you're probably
creating too much tension
around the larynx itself
or within the larynx itself.
And so this natural switch
of the energy placement
is being interrupted.
And so when I teach
the passaggio,
I just say keep
your vibrato loose.
Just let that vibrato go wild.
And usually that
helps them because it
keeps that larynx a little
more active and able to make
that switch on its own.
And that's what
the passaggio is.
And so knowing that also takes
the mystery out of it as well.
And I always think we need
to take more mystery out
of it, because when you get
your vocal technique organized,
that's just the beginning.
That's not the end product.
Having a good vocal technique
is the very beginning.
Because there's so much more
that goes into this business
than just having a
perfect vocal technique.
It might help if you
understood your words
and could walk and talk and
act at the same time as well.
That helps.
So that is what we do.
We create these formants
and these vowels.
And the speech
therapists do talk
about this resonant
pocket of the voice.
And that's when the
energies are not
being blocked by tensing
in the laryngeal area
somewhere or not
supporting properly.
The breath is a big thing.
Because singers experience
this compression
in their body in
very different ways.
As many people as are
singing would probably
describe the act of
inhalation and exhalation
during singing in
completely different ways.
However, I think one of the
most simple ways for you
to experience what we
experience is simply
we're all going to
do a sibilant S.
And you are going
to just hold this S.
And what you're
trying to do, you
don't want this S to go wavering
like a candle flame, you know?
You want to keep this S straight
down the middle of your tongue.
And you're just going
to go, and you're
going to experience the
slow the release of your air
through resistance.
Because that is what the
vocal cords are providing,
resistance on the air.
And so an S will
provide this resistance.
And you can experience what
the singer feels in their body
as they're slowly,
slowly releasing air.
So here we go.
How about a sibilant S?
So we're all going
to just go sss.
Do you feel your ribcage--
your ribcage is holding out
a little more, right?
You sense this ribcage
being held out.
Your stomach muscles
will suddenly
start to contract here and move
up the middle of your belly,
right?
Keep going, keep
going, keep going.
And when you get near the
end, then push it all out.
And do you feel how your
muscles in the stomach area just
then grip underneath, right?
Sss!
Right, if you-- sss!
Push it all out.
You feel that musculature.
That's what singers feel,
and that's what we're doing.
It is the relationship
of the amount
of breath pressure to the
amount of pressure into the cord
itself, which is critical.
And we learn to
control that slightly,
but the most critical thing is
that it's constantly flowing
and that you constantly
have a wealth of breath
in the reserve for
the voice to be using.
Breath motion is
critical, but every singer
has a different description for
what they sense in their body.
So Marilyn Horn
will say, push down.
I would never think of down.
I always think of
up with the breath.
But every singer has a different
response in their body.
And so they feel it
in a different way,
and they describe it
in a different way.
Of course, that's one of the
complications of teaching voice
in general, is that the
experience is internal.
Unless you've got a
scope in your house
and can scope yourself while
you're singing or something,
you don't know
what you're doing.
It's not like a pianist who
can adjust his wrist height,
a violinist-- I
played string bass--
adjusting the pressure of
how you hold your wrist.
You can see it all, and
it's much more simple.
This is a hidden
art form, in a way.
It's all in our
deep, dark throats.
One thing I wanted
to let you know
about the ee vowel--
all the vowels have
their set of formants.
And ee has a set of formants
out here at 2,000 and 3,000
hertz out here.
Guess what?
The 3,000 hertz is where the
human ear canal resonates.
So that's why the ee
vowel is usually one
of the most annoying vowels.
And I think voice
teachers, they teach away
from it a little bit, because
that ee really hits your ear.
Because if you go
ah, ee, ah, ee--
that ee-- ah comes
at you fairly well,
but ee, it just really
is more pungent.
We think of it as
the pungent vowel.
It is a pungent vowel.
But that's because
of a good reason.
It's the one that's
making your eardrums,
your actual ear canal vibrate.
So it literally has a
physical response for you.
So that's a good thing to know.
Because a physicist
asked me to show him
what I did in the
middle of my voice
to create more sound
if an orchestra got big
and I'm suddenly in
the middle of my range,
where a soprano
doesn't have much
punch in the middle
of our range.
And so he hooked me up to the
oscilloscope and all this,
and I showed him what I did.
And lo and behold, he said,
well, what you've done
is increase the ee formant.
Instinct on my part, but
that's what I was doing.
I instinctively
knew that that ee
formant what was going to
cut the orchestra better
than the other vowels.
So you learn those things.
So the vowels support.
Like I say, the
breath is so critical.
Now, of course, then we learn to
do fancy things with our voice.
I thought we could all
try doing staccati,
because staccatos
are very violent.
They should be anyway.
There are actually
two different kinds
of ways of accomplishing
this sort of a staccato.
One is what we call a laryngeal
staccato, where you're really
just using the cords themselves
rapidly and not really
diaphragmatically
impulsing this.
So that would be like--
[SINGING STACCATO]
It's not quite as strong for me.
I don't use those.
I use what is diaphragmatic.
The diaphragm is
that muscle that
lays in your body this way.
He is not flat.
This is not my diaphragm.
These are my stomach muscles.
My diaphragm is
in here this way.
He's under here, and when you
inhale-- it happens for us all.
When we inhale, the
diaphragm lowers and then
it slowly-- it's
what's controlling
this inhalation a little bit.
And it slows the inhalation
and the exhalation.
So here's a
diaphragmatic staccato.
[SINGING STACCATO]
And you can see
how violent I am.
[SINGING STACCATO]
And so guess what it's like?
Barking.
So if you always ah, ruff, ruff!
Everybody, barking?
Ruff!
But do you feel this?
You feel how this is
violently contracting on you?
That is a staccato.
That's what we learned.
Of course, your favorite
of the Queen of the night,
you know the--
[SINGING]
All that?
That's good staccato.
And a good queen of the
night has a really good
diaphragmatic action.
She knows how to get there.
So that's staccato.
And then a trill is one
of the hardest things.
You can't even teach it.
I've asked speech therapists.
I've asked everybody.
If you haven't got the
instinct for a trill,
it's probably not
going to happen.
And believe you me, I know
lots of really good singers
who can't trill.
But a trill is just
this oscillation
between two pitches.
That's what a trill is.
And there are trills on
half steps and trills
on whole steps.
But in the old days, guess what?
Back in the good old days,
when the baroque singers
were going wild, they
would trill on fifths.
So the baroque singer would go,
[SINGING]
They actually would
trill back and forth.
It's a little like yodeling.
But the trills that became
standard then from Mozart on,
basically, were mostly either
half step trills or full step
trills.
And those sound like,
[SINGING]
So I am literally setting
my larynx into a spasm.
It's really a spasm
of the larynx.
And like I say, I have never
been able to successfully teach
a trill.
But I can show you sort
of what it feels like.
And that's if you go,
[SINGING]
It's a little like doggies
again, a little barking.
But if you start on a
higher pitch and go down--
[SINGING]
We got some trills going on.
You see?
You can all trill.
So that's a trill,
and it's just being
able to get that larynx
to go into spasm.
My speech therapist friend,
I asked her and she said,
can't tell you how to teach it.
So if she doesn't know,
trust me, nobody does.
So the trill is this inherent
skill that you can develop.
So trills and-- oh gosh.
Where do we want
to go from here?
Let me see.
What have I got?
Staccato, coloratura--
Oh, singing fast,
singing fast notes.
We all know the-- I have
a baroque singer that
works with me who sings
a lot with Philharmonia
Baroque, a wonderful
girl named Celine Ricci.
And I always say to her, you can
sing faster than I can think.
My teacher always said,
because pitch is thought.
If you say to me
sing a high C, yeah?
If you don't indicate
what that pitch is,
my larynx doesn't know that.
I mean, if I hear the pitch,
my larynx goes-- bing!
He knows exactly.
So pitch is thought.
You can't come to a pitch
without thinking it.
So pitch being
thought, my teacher
would always say as fast as
you can think those notes you
should be able to sing them.
So one of my students
sitting back there,
the first thing we worked
on was "Rejoice Greatly"
from "The Messiah,"
which is something
that has a ton of coloratura.
And that's what I
taught myself to sing
my freshman year of college.
Because I was told I
was thinking that aria
at the big concert in
the basketball gym.
That's where you always have
to perform at Christmas.
And I went into that room.
I started at about 88
beats to the second.
And I got it up to about 132
by the time I was finished,
which as pretty quick.
So you know--
(SINGING) Rejoice,
rejoice, rejoice greatly!
Rejoice, O daughter of Zion.
All right.
So all this-- (SINGING)
O daughter of Zion.
Rejoice, rejoice.
Right?
So you learn those patterns,
and as long as you can think it,
I can go there.
But like I say,
my friend Celine,
she thinks faster than me.
That's for sure.
It's always astounding to me.
The really rapid coloratura
is always amazing.
Let's see.
Oh yes, and one of the other
things I wanted to mention
was that I could
go around this room
and probably pretty much nail
what kind of a voice type
you are.
Because there are body
types and head shapes,
neck shapes that sort of go--
Like, I see a
coloratura right here.
You see this lovely lady
in the purple jacket?
She has this beautiful,
long, swan neck.
And that always goes with
either the dramatic coloratura
or a lyric mezzo.
So I would say
she's either a lyric
mezzo or a dramatic coloratura.
Now, I see a possible
helden-something
back there, this gentleman
in the green t-shirt here.
Yes, you with the beard.
He's got this big head.
And he's got a nice thick neck.
And it looks like he's got a
nice long torso and a rather
wide torso.
He's either going to be a
heldentenor or some kind
of a big thick baritone.
Right back there, there he sits.
I'm looking at you.
I would suggest possibly a bass.
He looks like he
could be a bass.
Basses are often tall and lean.
Of course, there are
the basses also--
there are the short
little basses also.
But for instance,
coloraturas, there
are two kinds of the coloratura.
There's the French coloratura,
and they're usually short,
little short necks,
big round heads.
And those are the
French coloraturas.
And then the German
coloraturas are often
the bigger ones, more like
this with the long necks
and what I call the horse head.
It's a head that goes from here
to there, like a big cylinder
here.
And that's often the
dramatic coloraturas.
And believe me, it bears out.
I probably hear somewhere
between 800 and 1,000 singers
every year live in auditions.
And so when they walk in,
it's like I already know.
And some kids will
walk in, and they'll
say I'd like to sing this.
And I say, no you wouldn't.
[LAUGHTER]
No, you wouldn't.
Because I could tell.
I can tell by their
body type that they
couldn't sing that aria if
their life depended on them.
In reality, I mean,
to my standard
anyway-- to my
standard, they wouldn't
be able to execute it
because that body doesn't
sing that music.
It just doesn't happen.
This was one of the
most wonderful things
that happened to me.
After Dr. Courey had said
to me this whole business
about how you don't tell men
from females even if you stare
at the larynx all day long.
So one night, I'm doing
a public education class
on singing just like this,
just what I'm doing with you.
The orchestra members come
later and do their bit.
My friend, Emil Milan,
who's one of our cellists
in the orchestra, walked
in the room with his cello.
And I looked over there,
and I went, oh my god.
I thought, well,
whether you have
a Stradivarius or
a Suzuki, you're
walking into the
same music store
or emailing Amazon
for it, whatever,
how we do it anymore because
there are no music stores left.
They're purchasing
the same string.
It's not like he's got
a unique string that's
only the Stradivarius string.
No, he's going into a
store and buying a string,
replacing that string just
like any other violinist.
So guess what?
It ain't the string
that's so important.
It's the box.
So that's why these body
shapes are so critical.
Because my good
friend Dolora Zajick,
who has been one of the
world's famous dramatic mezzos
for years and years,
trained at the San Francisco
Opera, former Adler
Fellow, ding ding, right?
Dolora always says, when
I'm at a dinner party, when
we're sitting down,
I'm one of the tallest
people at the table.
When we stand up, I'm
one of the shortest.
Because she's all torso.
She is just nothing
but here to here,
big, long upper body,
and then teeny little
legs-- teeny little legs.
But that's her calling card.
That's why she is who she is.
And of course, she has a
head like a basketball.
[LAUGHTER]
My friend Jane
Eaglen, who was one
of the great
Brunhildes of her day,
you know, Jane, I literally
always just look at her head
and go, oh my god.
It's just a basketball.
It's a huge, huge head.
I've sung with [? Cort Mal, ?]
the famous bass.
It's just a mound!
He's a mound of a man.
He's just giant.
And that's what that voice is.
The body's tell you the truth.
Your body is your vessel.
And that was one of the great
things about seeing Emil
that night because it really
confirmed to me how important
this is to the act of singing.
So I always find that
very fascinating after all
these years of being
in this business.
So I think I'm about done
with what I have to say,
but I'm really anxious to hear
what you might want to know
and what questions
you might have.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I've been going
to the San Francisco Opera
since I was a kid.
SHERI GREENAWALD: Oh cool.
AUDIENCE: Huge opera fan.
But I have a question for you.
SHERI GREENAWALD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's not just about
the San Francisco Opera.
So I'm a native Russian speaker,
and I go to Russian operas
at the San Francisco Opera
and even other places.
And sometimes I'm
just horrified,
because there are some
singers that are just
butchering the language--
very sonorously--
but they're butchering it.
And there's another one who may
be not just Russian speakers.
You might have a Polish or
a Czech singer who are fine.
Same thing with
the Czech operas.
I'm hearing the same thing.
And then there's the one who
can't pronounce it correctly,
and I just cringe.
It's like grating on my ears.
I hear the same thing
with French operas.
Why do you guys hire people
who can't pronounce correctly?
And why do opera singers go
through all this training
and not learn to do the
French R, the rolling--
the Russian R and all these--
SHERI GREENAWALD:
French R-- French R,
even the French coaches don't
want us doing French R's.
French R's are left to
Edith Piaf and the crowd.
No, the preeminent
French coach is
Janine Reiss, who is one of
the famous French coaches.
You just don't use the French
R, basically, in what we do,
because it is a guttural thing,
and it's not good for singing.
If you're bringing it
[GURGLE] all the time,
you're going to irritate
your vocal cord, literally.
So you avoid that French R.
However, I'm with you.
One of my bugaboos in
the training of singers
is that we do not insist
upon language classes enough,
and language as a
language, not as
what we call the International
Phonetic Alphabet, IPA.
That's not enough, kids.
That's just not enough.
So when I was in
school I made a point
of studying these languages
individually-- German, French,
and Italian.
I made that point for myself,
but a lot of the schools
aren't doing it.
And that's the crime.
The Europeans, of
course, usually
come in much better
shape because they
speak many languages usually
growing up in their households.
I lived in Europe for 12 years.
I watched Italian TV,
French TV, German TV.
We watched it all.
British TV, thank goodness,
there was British TV.
"Ready, Steady,
Cook," I love you.
I mean, when Pamela Rosenberg
hired me at the San Francisco
Opera to be the head
of the training, one
of the questions she
asked me, she said,
what do you feel is the
most important thing
for a young singer?
And I said, languages.
And she, coming from Europe,
I think she appreciated that
tremendously.
And I think that's
why I got the job.
But I've been appalled at
really the paucity of language
training in the schools.
And it's just not
enough, and I'm with you.
I'm with you.
And I always get upset too
when they change the surtitles
to justify a thing.
And you know the
language and you
go, what's that got to do
with what they just said?
So anyway--
AUDIENCE: So how are
these singers even hired?
Because if they're competing
with singers coming from Europe
who may have better
language skills?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Well,
they could be a big star,
and so you know they're going
to pull in the audience.
So that's part of it.
The person hiring them
may not know any better,
may not know the
language either.
And so we forgive a lot
of stuff in this business
just because the person in
charge doesn't know it either.
But trust me.
When you come to the
San Francisco Opera,
we have coaches who are
absolute, assiduous hard
drivers.
But then there are
incorrigible people as well.
There are incorrigible
artists who just
aren't interested in changing.
But the coaches at the
San Francisco Opera,
I have been there.
I know.
They come after you.
You finish a stage rehearsal
and the diction coach
is chasing you down.
No!
You know, with a long
list, and you go ahh!
Believe me.
It's not like we want this
to happen, but like I say,
there are certain singers
who will be incorrigible.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sort of related.
So as with orchestral
play, voices
have to sound more homogenized
since the end of World War II.
But when you hear records
of some French singers,
some Russian singers,
some German singers,
there's a characteristic sound.
And I'm really curious
about your thoughts
about how these different
singing traditions wind up
with really such
distinctive sounds.
There's that Slavic sound
that's totally unmistakable.
SHERI GREENAWALD:
It's the language.
It will be their
native tongue that
has led them to a
certain set of resonances
that create a particular
style, if you will.
And so that is
absolutely-- I think it all
stems from the language itself.
Because if you want to get
very stylistic for anything,
if your language is incorrect,
the style will not be correct.
I think all of that comes
out of the language.
Also I think there is a
certain thing, for instance,
in the Asian face,
the way the nose is
on the Asian face or an
African-American face,
how our noses go on our face,
all of this kind of thing also.
So in certain ethnic groups,
a particular head shape
and a certain physiognomy
that is common to that race,
if you will, will also perhaps
influence a particular sound.
But I would say mostly
it'll come from the language
and what the native vowels
are creating for you.
That's where it
comes, I would say.
Yes?
My heldentenor, yes.
AUDIENCE: I have no idea
what that means though.
SHERI GREENAWALD: Oh, I
think he's a heldenbaritone.
Now that I hear him talk,
he's a heldenbaritone.
AUDIENCE: We want you
to take voice lessons.
AUDIENCE: I just started
like two months ago.
You were talking about {} our
meat box and the resonances.
How does that change
when you're on the move,
standing still versus acting?
When you were singing,
you were kind of like--
SHERI GREENAWALD: Moving around.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Well, a singing actor
has to be able to move and sing.
So what a singer
will do, always,
if you watch them on stage,
what they're going to try to do
is to keep this part of
their body equalized, sort
of the support box, if you
will, the cello part of it all.
You will try to keep that
in line a little bit.
But trust me.
I've sung laying down, falling
down, rolling down, on a sled.
I've sledded.
That was one of the
scariest things I ever
had to do was time a sled ride
down a hill to hit the tenor.
I had to hit the tenor.
That was the fun part.
The scary part was getting
that timing down with my sled.
I was in "Intermezzo"
in Santa Fe.
But yeah, you just
learn to do it.
If you think about Steph Curry
out on the basketball court--
go Warriors-- the positions,
his body gets into it.
You know that the core
strength has to be there.
So it's a lot about the
core strength for a singer.
AUDIENCE: You're really
using that movement
to help you hit some
note or something?
SHERI GREENAWALD: No, except
that it can liberate a singer.
Oftentimes, if I'm teaching
and their breath isn't moving,
if they're like, I
want to go home now
and you feel that sort
of strangled sense,
if you start getting them
to walk, they lose that.
And so sometimes you will
lead a singer around a room.
Or my colleague Mark Morash at
the opera, he always has them
twist.
Of course, now I say
to somebody twist,
and I have to explain
what a twist is.
Ahh!
But oftentimes we
will actually ask
them to move because that
will free up their breath.
Because that's so critical.
But you get used to singing
in lots of positions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the
production, typically
who [? shapes ?] the
implementation of the piece?
Is it the conductor, the singer?
And does that change
depending on the reputation
of the singer?
SHERI GREENAWALD: It can, yes.
I have watched
interesting confrontations
between conductors
and famous stars.
That can be very interesting.
I never had to worry about that.
But it's mostly the director,
in this day and age.
The concepts are going to come
from the director, of course,
for the production.
The conductor can come
in and influence it
in a great way, just
simply through tempo.
And oftentimes, there
will be a disconnect
between what the director
is wanting dramatically
and what the conductor
is thinking of the music.
And so sometimes, the
singer will end up
being the mediator
between the two of them
to find a compromise that
works for the dramatic side
and the musical side,
what he wants to create.
But in the old days, the
music dictated much more.
In today's world, the director
is a lot more ascendant
in the power struggles.
The singer is the last
one on the totem pole,
generally, unless
you're a big, big star.
When you're Renee
Fleming, when you're
Joyce DiDonato, when
you're Maria Callas,
you can dictate a lot more.
But even then, I'm
sure Callas was always
happy to have a [? seraphim ?]
in the pit, you know?
Someone who's strong, and
powerful, and can lead them.
You really do want to have
help when you're up there.
You're not looking to be
out there on your own.
You didn't get in the
business to be on your own
necessarily, so-- yes?
AUDIENCE: You've been
talking about formants
and the resonances for different
pitches and things like that.
I mean, like a flute or a guitar
is a one dimensional thing,
but in voice, you're
working at least
on maybe a height and a depth.
Things are happening in
at least two dimensions.
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Yes, I would say so.
Things are happening in all
dimensions, I think, with us.
It's very interesting.
I work with a flute player
who's studying voice with me.
And it's always interesting
to see the things
that I have to correct from
her because of the habits
she creates.
And flute players hold
their flute with their chin,
and so the chin becomes--
you've got to go, OK, ugh.
Get that thing out of there.
And it's very interesting,
the Meyer sound systems
that are coming
out now, which they
have in restaurants,
and theaters now,
and all of this sort of thing.
It's very interesting,
because I call them Ursula.
Because what they're doing
is taking my sensation away
from me.
A singer's relying very
much on a sensation.
It's too late when you hear it.
Like, the conductor
is always saying,
if you're waiting to
hear it, it's too late!
Conductors are always
yelling that at singers,
because oftentimes, you're
anywhere from 20 to 40 to maybe
even 50 feet away from the
source of the sound in the pit
and from the conductor.
And so you can't rely
on your ear at all.
You have to rely on your sight.
That's why the conductor is
important, believe it or not,
with the arms and so
you rely on your eyes
a lot more than
you do your ears.
And so that's one
of the things that's
complicated for me with
a Meyer sound system
is that they've taken away
the sensation that I rely on.
That's the thing that's
a problem for a singer,
I would say.
AUDIENCE: But when you know
a pitch that you want to
hit, you're going to have
to effectively choose how
to shape your vocal tract to--
SHERI GREENAWALD: I think
that pitch and I go.
What I just think about
is shaping the vowel.
I don't think about
shaping the tract,
because I really don't have
that much control over anything
except pitch when I'm
really down there unless I'm
doing things that I
think are going to be
detrimental to the production.
If I'm tightening this
band alongside the larynx,
or if you tighten the
atlas joint back here.
Guess where those muscles come?
Directly to your larynx.
And so if that joint is locked
up, you're screwed up too.
So there are a lot of
kinds of physiognomy things
that you deal with, but I
don't ever think about anything
but pitch laryngeally.
So everything else is
transferring that energy
past the larynx into
the resonant chamber.
So I'm working past my
larynx at all times, almost.
Because I only think of the
larynx as a pitch source,
and that's it.
AUDIENCE: Then how
are you going to teach
the students to create an
effective resonance so they
get enough volume?
SHERI GREENAWALD:
You've got to get
the vowel resonance correct.
That is the major thing.
You can't control the
pitch resonance other
than creating the pitch
correctly, or just creating
the pitch.
The pitch will have its
own set of resonances
that come with it,
but then the vowel
has its set of resonances.
And that's the
thing you can affect
is how they create
the vowel formants.
I would say that is what
teachers spend at least 80%
of the time doing, is actually
helping a student create
the vowel formants properly.
AUDIENCE: Along that line, so if
the conductors asking for more
volume, as a singer, we
think more resonance and ping
to get more volume
instead of push.
Do you do that
through vowel formant
or do you do that
through height?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Vowel formant,
working at the formants.
I was telling a story when
we were having lunch earlier.
Oh, I think I just I
told you that what I do
is increase that ee formant.
I told you that, yeah.
So that's about the only
thing I can do in an area
where I'm less resonant.
Now, of course a soprano
on a G, let's say.
You have middle C, C,
and then this G up here?
That's usually one
of our loudest notes.
We can get on that sucker and
go to town with most of them.
Put me up against a trumpet.
I'm there.
OK.
I'm ready to do it.
So you learn to do
it through formant.
Oh, that's an interesting thing.
That brings up the
subject of resonance.
There are two sides
of the resonance.
There's that thing
I talked about when
I talked about the breathy
onset, a more breathy onset
as opposed to a glottal or a
proper onset, a perfect onset.
There's also loft in the
sound or twang in the sound.
So loft is when
I talk like this.
There's a lot of
loft in my song.
I'm making a lot of back
space, and all of this,
it's very pharyngeal, really.
It's all more pharyngeal
space and breath back there.
But then twang, I'm closing up
space in the back, actually.
[TWANG]
We were watching a video
of Sam Ramey singing
the "Semiramide" aria.
And we were sitting
there, and Soha Al-Jurf,
my speech therapist friend
who used to be at UCSF,
would say loft,
twang, twang, twang.
Sam's from Kansas.
I said, Sam will
have a lot of twang.
He's a good Midwestern boy.
But those are sort of the
two shades of the resonance.
You can go from
[SINGING]
I have to go higher.
You can get-- you can
bring more twang into it.
So that's the two sides
of that resonant coin.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell us about
countertenors [INAUDIBLE]?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Countertenors,
basically, they're
singing on the
edges of the cords.
That is what they're doing.
And there's also a muscle that
runs through it, which I can't
think of the name of this vein.
And that thing is part of it.
But what they're
doing is that they
sing on the edge of the cords.
Females even, we
also have falsetto.
You just don't hear it
as such necessarily.
We call it whistle voice.
I'm sure you know about
whistle voice, right?
There's a whistle tone.
We actually have a falsetto too.
It's when you really get
to the edges of the cords,
and that's where
they're singing.
I've worked with a
lot of countertenors,
and it's very interesting work.
Because sometimes that
will just crack on them,
and it'll-- goes away.
But that's basically
what they're doing.
They sing with the
edge of the cord.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So a few weeks
ago, the San Jose Opera
had a production of
"The Magic Flute."
And I had a friend who worked
in the tech crew, and he said,
I can't believe it.
These singers, when
they're on the stage
and they have to speak,
you can't hear them
in the back of the hall.
And it's true.
I had one of the
cheap seats, and I
was like, I can't
hear what they're
saying when they had to speak.
And because they
didn't know German,
they actually had
to speak in English
and sing in German, which
was kind of bizarre.
Why?
Why is this?
If they can sing so well
and then when they speak--
SHERI GREENAWALD: Because it's
what I always say to girls.
I imagine, did you
hear the men better
than you heard the women?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Because men are generally
singing where they speak.
So a baritone is,
basically-- I always
say baritones never learn
how to sing because they
sing where they speak.
That's my little joke.
Sorry, my baritone friends.
But they sing where they speak.
The problem for
us, for sopranos,
the modal-- that's called
the modal part of the voice.
It's where you are
speaking all the time.
And as you hear me,
I speak quite low.
I'm a soprano, but I generally
am speaking at below middle C,
almost invariably.
So if I try to
project down here,
I don't have any sound down
here unless (LOW VOICE)
I were to go into a
chest voice and do that.
But there's no
character that I would
do that would have that voice.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, there just wasn't.
For instance, I did a lot of
"Rosalindas," but in English,
in Santa Fe.
I did a ton of them.
And so I always
said, would it not
be stupid if I was on stage
talking like, (LOW VOICE)
well now, Alfred.
Come over here, Alfred.
And then all of a sudden,
I start to sing and I'm--
(SINGING SOPRANO) At night,
when I'm alone with you--
It's like, what kind of
a disconnect is that?
(HIGH VOICE) So
when I'm on stage,
I will speak much more up here.
Oh darling, really, must you?
Because now I'm in
a pitch range where
I have resonance that
I can use to project.
And so I bet you those
women weren't pitching
their voices very high.
AUDIENCE: No.
SHERI GREENAWALD: No,
that's the mistake.
Females have to pitch
their voice higher on stage
if you're going to project.
I mean, most theaters
where actresses and stuff,
they're not as big
as what we sing into.
They don't have that same issue
because they're not projecting
into this larger space.
But a singer, if you're on
stage at the San Francisco--
(SINGING SOPRANO)
Opera, you'd better
be up here, where you've
got a little resonance
and you can make some noise.
And probably you can
hear me back there.
So that's what I
would say is that they
weren't using their
upper resonances nearly
enough to speak.
That's what would happen.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
the passaggio and [INAUDIBLE].
Could you describe what
happens physiologically
when you use what, I guess
you call the mixed voice?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Well, I would
say the mixed voice is probably
where those two muscles,
the thyroarytenoid
and the cricoarytenoid,
are evened out.
That's where I would say
the tensions from both
are of an equal tension.
I would say that
that's what you sense
and you experience as
the mix in the voice.
The mix in the voice is where
you have this head voice
and you chest voice.
Ahh.
And that's just the two
ends of the instrument.
And in the middle,
where they start to mix,
we call that the
mix in the voice.
And so a mixed voice, if I'm
coming down from the head
voice, I'm going--
[SINGING]
Now I'm in my mixed.
Did you hear?
Suddenly, it became thicker.
[SINGING]
Right there, the chest sound
came much more into my sound
there.
[SINGING]
Now if I go down--
Now I let myself
go into full chest.
And that's full chest.
So you've heard the
head, mix, and chest.
That's the three
descriptions of what
we experience acoustically.
That's what that is.
But it's really just a function
of the pitch resonances,
really.
That's a pitch resonance thing.
Yes, my tenor.
AUDIENCE: I'm vaguely aware
of professional singers, not
necessarily opera singers,
who have to go on rest
or they drink fancy tea
or weird stuff happens.
Physiologically,
what's going wrong?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Well--
AUDIENCE: It's all in our head.
SHERI GREENAWALD: That's right.
It's all in their head.
Usually, it is.
Well, it's so interesting.
My speech therapist friend
always says, remember,
a singer is a human being.
And human tissue is
a lot more delicate
than a piano string, for
instance, or the cat gut
that the cellist plays on.
So we are dealing
with living tissue.
And so singers get obsessed
about that sensation.
Every singer has their fetishes.
I had one baritone friend.
You'd walk into
his dressing room,
and there would be little
towel in the middle.
And all the brushes
were neatly laid out.
And this was his fetish.
This is my prep.
Now, my room wasn't
anything like that.
However, I went through
my phase of Ricola tea,
where I dropped
about 10 Ricola drops
into a canister of hot water.
And that was the Ricola
tea for the night.
Singers will experience
things like cotton mouth.
You if you get nervous,
all of a sudden,
you feel like your mouth
has just dried up entirely.
So the good thing about
Coca-Cola and Ricola tea
is that they've
got sugar in them
and they'll stimulate
your saliva.
So that helps you keep
a sense of moisture.
And of course, you
have to stay hydrated.
That is critical.
Because you are bringing
a lot of hot air.
[LAUGHTER]
A lot of hot air in and out.
There's a lot of
hot air in and out.
So you are drying tissue.
So staying hydrated
is very critical.
I don't know any singer--
I'm an old singer
and I'm still traveling
with my water bottle.
So we just get
obsessed with water.
That's what we do.
And it's just
because we're human.
We have to be.
That's it.
But every singer has a
fetish about their routine
coming into the theater.
So it's always amusing.
I always am amused, anyway.
Anyone, yes?
AUDIENCE: What was the
most challenging language
to sing in?
SHERI GREENAWALD: I
love singing in Russian.
I loved Russian.
Actually, I never found
any of the languages
thus far too difficult. I
love singing in Spanish.
Italian was my least
favorite, actually.
Oddly, I loved
singing in German.
I loved Russian.
I like the consonants.
Ahh.
I like consonants.
And of course, I spoke French.
I lived in France.
I love singing in French.
But yeah, there was
nothing, no language
that I ran into in my end of
the business that frustrated me.
I liked them all.
I was always fascinated by them.
I mean, any singer probably
has this weird vocabulary
because you have
words that you've
learned in a particular
language that are so fitting.
Like, I'm always calling-- I
have to even stop and think
in English.
The litter box-- to
me, that's the bakje.
That's a Dutch term, the bakje.
That's a perfect word.
It's short, succinct.
You don't have to
say "litter box."
That's too long.
Bakje.
There it is.
So every singer
has all these terms
from all these other languages
that you constantly are
peppering your statements with.
Because you just like language.
Hopefully, you like languages.
That's critical, as
we spoke earlier.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Who's your
favorite pop singer?
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Favorite pop singer?
Oh.
Well, right now, I got Tom
Petty going on in the car.
I love that album,
the White Album.
I called it the White Album.
I don't even know what the
album is, but I love the line, "
(SINGING) "You gotta have
rhino skin if you're gonna fit
in this world."
So I love Tom Petty.
I like me some Annie Lennox.
Give me some Bette Midler even.
Bette Midler's on tour again.
I love it.
I've seen her in Amsterdam.
I've seen her in all
kinds of places, Bette.
So I like all kinds of music.
Every opera singer does.
Most opera singers have a lot
of rock 'n' roll on their iPads.
Believe me.
They really do.
They love their rock.
Love to go Country
Western dancing too.
Well, Country Western
singing is really nice.
It's a lot of twang.
Got a lot of good resonance
in Country Western
singing, like the Country
Western singers a lot.
Good twang.
Anybody in from Iowa?
We got a bottle of twang in it.
I always laughed about the Loud
family on "Saturday Night Live"
because I thought
that's where I grew up.
That was my family,
the Loud family!
So we're very loud in my family.
Anyone else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What role
outside your repertoire
would you love to sing if
you had that voice type?
SHERI GREENAWALD:
Brunhilde, no doubt.
I always say with the
way things are digitizing
and everybody's
doing all this stuff,
I said, just put on the
Birgit Nillson recording
and let me at it.
I was a good lip syncher.
I did a lot a lip
synching as a young girl.
So I'm sure I could
figure it out.
So Brunhilde would be the role.
AUDIENCE: You'll have to
settle for [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So after "Britain's
Got Talent" had Susan Boyle
and I forgot the man's name
who was a cell phone salesman
and then became an
opera singer, and then
now with the
simulcast, my parents,
they're like, why go all
the way to San Francisco?
I can just drive you to the
AMC and watch a movie there?
Do you think that's sparking
more interest in opera?
Because I know it's very
difficult financially
with arts funding and all that.
What do you see as the future?
SHERI GREENAWALD: Well, I think
it's a double-edged sword.
Unfortunately, I do feel that
a lot of all this simulcasting
and stuff does cannibalize the
audience for the actual opera
houses.
And the problem is opera is an
expensive art form to produce.
And so if you start that, then
you won't have even the source.
If you don't support
the source company,
then you won't have the source
to even make your simulcast.
So it's a complicated
question, and it's one
that I don't think has
gotten sorted out at all.
Like, I think the Met having
a simulcast a few blocks
from their house, I think has
cannibalized their audiences
rather.
So it's a complicated
question business-wise.
Is it good for the people?
Absolutely.
Are you kidding?
It's fantastic.
Get opera.
Let people see it.
You can go online and see
opera almost anywhere any time.
That's amazing.
But for the financials
of our business,
it's a complicated question.
It's more complicated than
people think, I think.
So yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I'm more familiar
with the symphony side,
going [INAUDIBLE] and seeing
the vocal soloist there,
and the chorus, and all that.
What is the behind the
scenes for the vocal soloist?
And if you had an opportunity
to go the symphony
and sing something
versus the opera,
other than in one you act and
in the other you generally
don't, are there
other differences
in performing in the two spaces?
SHERI GREENAWALD: No,
I was lucky enough
I got to do both, of course.
Most singers do get to do
symphonic work as well.
It's not really
that much different.
I mean, however, for instance,
the great Tatiana Troyanos,
who was one of the
famous mezzo sopranos,
I remember I was sitting in her
manager's apartment in New York
City.
And the phone rings, and
it's Tatiana on the other,
and she's singing the Alexander
Nevksy suite with the Chicago
Symphony, with Schulte
conducting, right?
This is not a small profile gig.
This is a big profile gig.
Phone rings, and it's Tatiana.
(PANICKY) I can't sit on
the stage the whole night
and have people looking at me!
I can't do this!
And she was completely
flipping out
because she was going to
have to sit on the stage.
And I've seen her on stage.
I saw her on stage at the San
Francisco Symphony in concert.
She was completely
uncomfortable with that.
As long as she had a character
to hide behind, she was fine.
But the whole idea
of sitting on stage
as yourself was really
freaky for some singers.
So I would say that
that's the difference.
It's that you are more yourself
when you're doing a concert.
Of course, at the
opera, you are involved
in a complete
character development.
So it's more naked singing
symphonic pieces, in a way,
if you will.
It feels more naked, in a way.
So some people are better
suited to that than others.
Like I said, help!
But that didn't bother me.
Happy to deliver my
message wherever.
I love singing "The Messiah."
I loved singing that down.
My favorite recording
of "The Messiah"
is one with the great
dramatic tenor John Vickers.
Because I always say, when
John Vickers opens the thing
and goes, comfort
ye, you go, yes, sir.
There's no doubt you're
going to comfort yourself.
Yes, sir.
I will.
And the great thing
about that recording
is it's the great Birgit Nilsson
singing the soprano solos.
It's hilarious.
It's one of my
favorite recordings.
This giant dramatic
voice like, rejoice!
And it's like heaven on a stick.
You've got to love it.
But I would say
that's the difference.
It's that you feel
more naked when
you're out there as a
soloist than in a symphony.
And so many symphonic disasters
in that little stupid things
will happen like
my girlfriend, who
was singing "The Messiah"
with me at the San Francisco
Symphony, the conductor
had changed the order
of a few of the pieces.
And so during one
thing, she got up.
And I'm sitting there
going, wait a minute.
Don't-- And then she smiled
very nicely and sat back down.
It's like, OK.
OK.
And one of my favorite stories,
my friend Neil Rosenshein
loves to tell this
story about himself.
He was singing "Loge"
in some final scene
of-- must have been "Valkyrie,"
or maybe "Goetterdaemmerung."
Might have been
"Goetterdaemmerung," actually.
"Goetterdaemmerung" it was.
And he had one line to sing.
He was an apprentice
artist there,
and they filled in all the
smaller roles in this scene.
And he too, he said, I got
up and the conductor didn't
cue me, and I sat back down.
Those are my favorite stories.
I like those.
Whoops.
Oh, well.
Sorry, sorry.
There's nothing worse than
you make a wrong entrance
and you-- whoa.
(SINGING) Now, I think I'm now!
Here I am now, all right.
Hopefully, a conductor's there.
You know a good conductor.
They got a good left hand.
Shh.
Now.
That's what they
do-- stick a hand up.
Stop you.
Now.
But a good conductor has that
independent hand, you know?
He can keep this tempo going
and this one stopping you.
I don't know that I'd
be that coordinated,
but anyway, a good conductor
can do that though.
Thank goodness they're there.
Anybody else?
It's fun singing.
Please, come to the opera.
Support us one way or the other.
Go to the simulcast, but
coming live is even better.
I always refer back to
this wonderful statement
by a friend of mine
who's a doctor.
He's a radiologist in
the St. Louis area.
And he was on the board
of the St. Louis opera.
So I said to him, Doc, why is it
you're so obsessed with opera?
And he said when
I'm in that theater,
and that voice
comes, and hits me
in the chest, that's
what I love and that's
what I'm addicted to.
So you can't have that,
I'm afraid in the theater.
That's a live experience, and I
hope you come in and enjoy it.
KRISTIN GENIS-LUND:
Thank you so much.
SHERI GREENAWALD: Thank you.
KRISTIN GENIS-LUND:
Everybody, you're wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
SHERI GREENAWALD:
You're welcome.